all right and we are live
the last word with lor cognito and
ibontes fresh
on that friday morning campfire nice
little you know
setup going on today some good guests
what's going on man first e how are you
doing sir all right let's go uh a little
short on sleep as i stayed up late for
eternal
um and then i had to stay up another
hour to start return
thanks to ps5 saying hey it's gonna be
ready at 10 11 i'm sorry i just messed
up so that was fun
returning was fantastic i got one run in
about 90 minutes i'm gonna be streaming
that later
really really cool so far love what it's
doing um yeah
cannot wait to dive into that but other
games aside we also have had some spicy
swabs recently we got a lot of
information and we've got an excellent
guest
to talk about all of this destiny
information about so
back to you sir let's do this as we only
do let's bring them in
all right welcome to the last word
episode number 147
and it's glorious friday we're back in
front of the campfire for some more
lunar shooter discussion
i'm extremely excited about our special
guest so we're gonna get right into it
i want to introduce a lord whose passion
for the destiny franchise and hilarious
swear jar interactions with this
community make you
easily fly to the chaperone wielding
void hunter
introducing the created host of the
pigeon twitch and pigeon 88 youtube
channel
the lord of guitar covers most
infectious laughing pvp and the only man
to survive brain freeze while eating a
whole cornetto or a tree
riding from scotland and making his
debut at the campfire of the last
word mommy lord pigeon how are you doing
sir
good morning i'm good afternoon anyone
that said turning from
my side to the point that i'm not gonna
lie that is the best introduction i have
ever had
like the ice cream thing got me by the
way
oh man because when i saw it i was
howling left i have never done that
again mine that was
potentially the most like fleet of the
moment worst decision i've ever made
it's good to be here thanks for having
us in i respect how early you guys are
up
uh to get the podcast going i'm not a
morning person so
it's good to know that i got at least
the plus five hours to
have us news and do what i had to do so
yeah it's good to be here hello pleasure
to have you man we got some some quest
couple questions for the man you know
it's limited time we've got some
questions right here i'll let you jump
in
uh just want to say like i know like
you're going through university and
stuff like that right now but your
gaming history goes back
fairly far so how has it been
like who got you who got you into gaming
and just what are some like highlights
along the way
um of your kind of gaming history yeah
so i mind talking about this briefly and
like the first game ever played was
sonic hedgehog on a second mega drive
system
there was like an old family photo of me
setting up a tv controller in hand
sonic's on the telly you can see the
mega drive with the car she's out
yes like sticking out and i'm sitting
there playing it so that was kind of my
first
uh like that one in games and my dad
he's always worked in it
for jobs so he was always kind of up to
speed with that sort of thing
and he always got went to get the latest
consoles so it was the sega mega drive
it was a
sega saturn
when i got an n64 and then like a
playstation that stuff was
the game changers growing up i remember
like coming home from school playing
playstation constantly oh yeah
now you you i got to stop in for a
second because you you you do the mega
drive stuff is classic like that is like
you're in his sega bag right you touch
the touch of the heart
with that one right so salute to you on
that i want to um
yeah sega kid all day oh yeah oh there
and mega drive was the ringtone by the
way
i did if i had a text stone and it was a
sega
fanfare uh it had to be done now i'm
just purging
growing up so i respect the sega love
hardcore
you also got the playstation one love
there's a specific
game though that i saw that i gotta ask
you that
really touched me now a lot of people
talk about this in the playstation one
sue coden caught in yeah
talk to me more specifically according
to
so um my i had a lot of relatives who
were into their rpgs
they were older relatives and uh coding
was one of the first games that i
watched them play
on their playstations because like
family time was going around each
other's houses and like guys staying
tonight
or um just hanging out after dinner that
sort of thing
and uh i would we would all go around
the tv and this is one of those
like i don't know cultural things but
in the like family houses in scotland
like there was
the big tv which was in the living area
yeah you know where we're going like the
kids crap tv in the corner
right but uh we had this we used to
visit my grandparents house
on the weekly and they just let us use
the big tv that was that
so after dinner we're all crowded around
watching
like the eldest cousin playing uh
playstation games or whatever console
and
thing was relevant and so coding was one
of the first games that stood out to me
so sitting there
reading all the story getting involved
in everything that was going on
and uh eventually that became me going
to my parents can i
can i get that to coding game and
like it was not a mess actually just
asking for a video game but
i i was lucky enough that my parents
like picked it up at one point have like
visited like the shopping centers and
that's that's where it started yeah rpgs
recording
um i always just remember
like i had i no idea what was going on
by the way
i didn't play in it i was like this is
that i'm that person though i think it's
because you've got to name your
characters and stuff like that
that was like a big thing so you would
name them after
you would name them after everybody in
the family and stuff so that was like a
big
selling place yeah
and but i remember at that point in time
the trailers were out for final fantasy
vii on playstation
and like that week i'd see a trailer for
firefighters seven i'm like okay okay
and then by the time i went to my
grandparents that that weekend they were
ill discussing had film fantasy seven
and
sitting playing it and we were just
sitting there watching like the macro
reactor sequence
just pure like i'm not even kidding
sitting cross-legged on the floor
oh yeah like this far from the tv like
yes
yeah oh oh man
so you got like n64 i know you played
golden i
got final fantasies so this like which
is brew of rpg
shooters then all of a sudden you know
you you get the perfect one that comes
out you get destiny
like how how do you go
from all of that you skip halo though
the whole thing right and then get to
destiny
so that like not didn't quite skip
payload so
in the sense of what consoles i had
growing up i never owned an xbox until
way late in the game so my only
experience with playing halo
was going to friends houses so like
would be a night out in the town and
then i'd wake up the next day crashing
at a friend's place
the xbox was sitting there they were
still passed out in the bedroom like
i'm going to play halo because i don't
care and they would come in and they'd
see me start playing halo and to them
there was no norway because they played
it to the death i'm sitting on this i
love this game
um so i was was was looking for like a
halo esque shooter but for playstation
and i had well playstation 3 4 at the
time
and uh by chance i was in
my local game shop and there was like a
pre-owned section so i don't know if
they do that stateside like you get
discount games because they've been
there yeah
those adventure games and i play i
picked up destiny one
at that that time without even realizing
i just looked at it right cool
took them home i actually jammed destiny
one in first
and it had it was at the time before i
knew
it was in its second year like year two
and a half okay
so i had the massive update to do so i
couldn't play it so it's already cool
so i put on bloodborne i was like right
cool and i'd never played the front i
never played a song
i mean i started with that too actually
that was my first one
oh it was your first thought yeah yeah
so i didn't know about the brutal
difficulty
that these games that shout to you and
uh
i pretty much played it and i was like
no i can't
i couldn't i couldn't stand it dying
constantly as i recall
so the next day comes that's this i was
on a holiday at the time because
that's what i did i started my holidays
like i'll go buy some new games to play
well i'm off
this week or whatever so the next day
destiny one had installed this update
and i pushed play on it yeah and i'm not
even kidding
literally the moment i fired the first
gun
that tactile feedback on the controller
that just imitated halo
it was just familiar and then seen
damage numbers on the screen
everything just went i was just sitting
there i was like
yeah yeah yep that's it it all clicked
like obviously the segway earlier was
to coden i played all the fair fantasy
games i love rpgs in that sense
but the other thing i missed actually
was i was a big call of duty player
i played that with friends on
playstation 3. what the warfare 2
was a game changer oh class yeah yeah i
mean that was that one
yeah i was trying to manchester i mean
still
and i'm like that's not me i'm i'm not
doing that
absolutely so that was one of the games
as well and the more
common sense before destiny so i had
that uh
that feel for like more modernized
first-person shooters like call of duty
and and then i found destiny that day
the same way i just told you so
yeah the rest was history i i honestly
couldn't tell you i just looked and
believed that after that
is there anything that's pulled you away
from destiny
like any cool experiences like i know
we've touched outright or stuff like
that
any big ones that pulled you in and be
like damn this was really good and still
sticks out in the course of like
destiny's like obviously like we live
and breed this thing but is there
anything in that seven years that's been
like
yeah that was still a good thing to step
away for any big ones like that oh yeah
uh i've been a big fan i like got the
war i remember buying
remember i remember getting got the war
and going uh
to play that campaign as at that was
right during war mind if i remember
right
and foreign
[Music]
that's when we started our podcast
because we got it here yeah
yeah oh nice there you go then i
um so i played god of war i play a lot
of single player games
offline uh i've recently started getting
a lot more metroidvania stuff
and the whole night series have you
played ori
i'm playing order right now dude i just
finished the second one dude
i just did one and two tuesday and day
man
have you have you cried between any of
those games yet have they hit you like
i've heard that one from my phone
definitely mine oh dude i was on stream
and i had to shut the camera off because
i'm just sitting there like
dude i it got me like oh man
it gets quite emotional for sure i was
like
i played ori i had i had that or i
bought it on steam actually
the second audience five both of them
are on the xbox games class so
um i went back completely dory
and then i was like right i'll play ori
this is the second one so i'm playing
that just now one of the things i like
to do is like
play my discord off on my off days from
streaming
and that gives people a chance to come
and hang out enjoy an adventure story
that sort of thing
nice um other than that recently i've
been playing
some apex i like the rush of just
getting them doing some pvp win or lose
that's a lot of fun
like just been in a game mode are you
excited for arenas
um yeah i'm pumped i think definitely
going to try that on lunch
um i mean it's good that we get grace a
week's grace before the the next destiny
season so
that'll be something to do just a little
bit of time but yeah
may is actually somehow stacked so i
i'm pretty sure there's a conspiracy
they all know each other
well cause we got returnal we've got
resident evil
destiny biomutant and now arenas is in
there too i'm like can we not like can
we
space this out please it's like you're
in college and or university for you and
you're just like
hey you guys need this all on the same
day cool perfect timing thank you like
same thing so oh yeah oh yeah okay man
it's always soft event yeah i wanted to
talk to you about you know real quick
content creation as far as like
i think one of the like first of all
you're hilarious so i got a salute to
that like very entertaining super funny
i think the funniest thing i saw for
like you had um you were doing like the
the chat goes like no swearing for 10
minutes
yeah wait it's gonna be that's gonna be
tough that's gonna be tough yeah
wow so tell me about that and that's it
and i think that
yeah like a situation with uh google and
i saw i was dying bro it was so funny
you were trying to say it
and then you you broke the protocol and
you swore my face
yeah my face is going red here right so
one of my favorite things one of my
favorite things on twitch one of the
tools i give you is the the channel
point redemptions and you can have a lot
of fun with them
so and i recently moved back home i mean
i was in a flat in glasgow city center
uh bad to move out due to circumstances
but
couldn't move anybody else so i'm back
at my parents just now
and my mum is always telling me to stop
swim
now uh i asked the dance here if what's
the ak on swearing on
on the podcast i was like i'll do my
best
so uh one evening or sit until now
and my mom came into the room and she
was like blah blah blah i was like blah
blah blah i was like come say hi
and then she's like stop your swearing
and i was just like hi okay i'll try
and then i'd ended up almost throwing
straight away there then i was like oh
i was like i've got the button i've got
the button
like that so that's where that started
and i thought you know what
we'll do a redemption for my q a to make
sure i don't swear for
10 minutes i think that's reasonable
yeah you can hold it we recently
we've recently decided to make a swear
jar so if i fail
i was about to say f up there by the way
he's getting better the jar is working
the jars working good job
if i fail then uh we've got a set of
charities which we'll
donate to or i would donate too
so this one incident i someone redeemed
it in chat
so for my timer i'm using my phone and i
go where i was going to beep here go
hey google right it didn't pick me up oh
no i didn't
so i did that and google took so many
like
turns to get the timer going that ended
up swearing at my phone before
to not swear for 10 minutes i loved it
absolute disaster i was like we're done
here
[Laughter]
you're like i'll just throw like 10
bucks in the jar it's fine i'll just get
done with it that's amazing yeah you
gotta see it
i think you've got it up on tic tac toe
yeah i'll go look
oh yeah it was a good clip that was a
great clip
something to take a lot of pride in as
just like organic moments like that just
so so inwardly me that you can't
it's just yeah and yeah that's that's
what i love about having
like the live stream because it captures
that and that was just
it was brilliant and people always would
people do redeeming the daily
um so yeah that's a definite feature
that's a perfect one um yeah that's kind
of one of those things too it's like
i try and be reasonable when i do my
videos i really try and keep it clean
one because i know my two nephews are
like watch all of them so i definitely
have a younger audience there at least
two of them that will
my brother would be like dude can you
stop um
so he would call me out but on the other
side when you said the live stuff on
stream that is truly some of the best
pieces about
being live and it was like hey when it
was oriented i'm sitting here i'm just
like watching this i'm like guys
and they're like tear-jerking like
little emotes and chatting over here
like
all right i gotta like wipe the eyes you
guys like know what's happening right
now but same thing for you it's like
when they're like
when you have those moments with your
community
and you hit like the swear jar or like
you know the brain freeze and all those
things that go through it's like
that's one of those things about
streaming that nothing else kind of
captures and when you've got a community
and yours has just been exploding so
congratulations yours is
awesome but when you get those moments
it's like ah those just like stick and
then it's like then it's like inside
jokes for those who are there and it
just hangs around for a while it's
awesome
yeah absolutely absolutely i love it man
what it is is you have a lot of fun
and i love that in community last
question for you is the
pigeon name and the coop yeah
how did the whole how did you adopt the
pigeon man why did that become
part of it's not a it's not a glorious
fancy bird so not gonna know like
bald eagles yeah no like just you know
asian
so like there's so many stories that i
told over the years now it was it was a
nickname
originally uh from high school and the
source of that
on its own is like a mystery the one
story i've always stuck to
at the time was i had really bad posture
i'm
a taller person so i used to walk with
quite a
slouch and i actually can't remember
being like that i just walked through a
slouch my head was down and
someone just someone and the group like
the the communal area at school just
said you walk like a pigeon
or something like that and people just
started calling me pigeon
oh and uh
that that's just that's all i know at
the time but uh
fast forwards i got i i loved social
media growing up so
my space came into my life and i
kind of adapted the pigeon name and i
typed it the exact way
you see it today like all those years
ago all those years ago
and it stuck as a nickname so it went on
my psn it went on like my
gaming accounts and it was it was just
everywhere that was
a nickname and it was it was just that
i don't know it was a screen name as
well i guess and
eventually like i made a twitch account
and i mean i wasn't serious at the time
but at least i'm actually to stay glad
that i nab
the the prison and yeah url and all that
and
not knowing how serious it would all get
but that's kind of where it started from
the nickname and people always
remembered it i think the one thing was
anybody ever met in my life
people always remember that name it was
very easy to remember oh yeah
as well so i think that on its own was
just a bit of a blessing
and i kind of got lucky with that one uh
so i that's the unofficial story of the
name pidgeon
as far as the community name like i
didn't know it was just
in the moment it might make sense yeah i
was just like i made a discord one day
uh i'd been i'd started streaming again
i was like i need to make a discord now
and try and get
a proper like everything going offline
and i just called i just like pigeon
something
pissing coupe and that just
again so
that was the discord name and then that
became the community name as well
i love how you adopted it love hearing
it the history behind it and fun
community fun community man salute to
you definitely
keep up the good work sir thank you so
much the last one i
like last one i got to get in though um
and you said it as well
a lot of twitch is not only american but
like how
often are you frequently asked about
what did you say
or the accent and things like that
because there's little things like
when we're sitting here talking like
okay i got took me like a second to get
there but
is that like a common thing which you're
like translating your own speech every
so often people just like
kind of roll with it and not not a big
deal that's quite funny to die
because i recently added closed captions
to the stream
um and some people have had them on and
they've read back some of the things
that's been said like one of my friends
in chat
uh oddpod you might see him there he was
he was renamed ipod
um honestly like there is a semi
language fire because like
when even though i'm scottish i've also
got a whole set of slang and
dragon that i use that people might
understand but i'm not kidding a lot of
people
have came the streams said i have no
idea what you're saying
blood they love it and i'm just like
tell you what watch this some more
you'll eventually understand what it's
all about and
honestly i think that's actually kind of
stuck a lot of people have um
understood eventually started to
understand what i'm saying if not
they can just kind of brush over or get
get the gist of what i'm saying
when i say it so no that's a
yeah what does that mean but i also
think a lot of people
don't hear a scottish accent yeah it's
not
that yeah it's not that you hear you
know you probably hear british or
other things like that but scottish is
actually not that often so you're
probably uh
you know a rare one out there are there
any give us two cool slang words and
then we'll move
two cool sides because i feel like
you've even corrected me on twitter
before like
i feel like i asked somebody scottish
and like you almost chimed in a long
time ago i remember that but yeah give
me two slang words that are cool
dude i couldn't like come up with them
off the top of my head because they just
just flows just roll out i think you
yeah for us we're like mesmerized
they well ah there was one other other
day
like a simple one please would be all
right
all right so that it's just all right
but it'll be like all right
i would type it a w right so be all
right so that's
how you think
i used to actually uh roomed with
someone from california
and they were obsessed with the scottish
accent and
one of the the ones is obviously like
there's been a murder
and it's because when you're scottish
they've got stronger
it's hard yeah
i watched one of these things already
one of my friends put a video about
scottish slang and i've
mre
all right nice nice
yeah man good history good stuff we got
to get into some
what's going on with this game man yeah
so how's
uh which class are you guys supporting
uh just to clarify
titan here we got uh you know warlock
delegation here
yeah i'm been up in the lazy hot oh man
i've been a cliche
lazy you're living up to the bill there
sir way to go holding
holding strong is anybody gonna get the
um
challenge triumph for like the 75 out of
77 is anybody going to check the box for
all of them
or have you already done it pigeon
not
the whole complete everything i do i
just play the game the way i want to
play it
so probably for the best yeah if someone
asked me to deviate how i play then i'm
very unlikely to unless there's like a
a good reward
yeah and unfortunately it's like the
4000 brightness i'm like i'll spin the
four bucks if i really need it i'm good
i don't i don't care that much but the
big first news
i gotta let my man with the rose tinted
glasses talk about his favorites
over there i had to do it
i had to do it did you bespoke
my moment my vow by voting how
dare you oh that was too easy
anyways we got something coming up next
season and sir you gotta tell them
yeah they're ready set raid they put the
dudes out man
in case you haven't heard the vault of
glass is coming back
go live on may 22nd at 10 a.m pacific
standard time i'm sorry what day of the
week is that
saturday that's good for everybody
that's good for everyone we got more
things that are good for everyone when
we
when we hear about it so yeah man they
basically said that um we're going to go
up against atheon again and uh story the
story isn't changing but
we may notice differences they said our
goal was keep it uh similar to
feel similar how we remember but we made
some updates to bring this content
up to destiny to standards so again
we're doing that then they got the uh
world's first
race they said they talk about that kick
it off in 2014 they want to know how
they want to recapture the moment
so basically these are the things
they're going to uh shake up the race
with
so it will launch with contest mode
enabled
for 24 hours now this was big you need
to be
only at 1300 power check already done
yep to be at the cap for all that is
huge that is that's honestly smart
and smart more engagement everyone's in
clearing voltage
voltage glass with context mode active
is the first step to access the new
challenge mode
in the director and the temple's edge
triumph
completing temple's edge security list
of triumphs in this newly unlocked
challenge mode
will be how a fire team crosses the
world's first finish line and claims
their prize
to enforce the triumph requirements in
the challenge mode your team will wipe
if you fail the success conditions
during each
encounter huge deal we see the belt
we see what's going on with that 80 on
on the side so what do you guys think
you know
real quick as far as uh challenge mode
all this good stuff the man who owns the
coop you go first
get with the cool thoughts on it yeah
what you thinking pigeon
is it's going to be so interesting you
re we really hope i
will say what i'm hoping for i'm hoping
for some solid
like updating because like i've been
doing a lot of d1 raids recently
and when you play bottle glass there's
all that nostalgia
that never stops but when you actually
get down to the core gameplay you
realize it's very
primitive mechanics from the games or
obviously it's first rate so
um hopefully we'll see some like
evolution for how that
feels in destiny 2. hopefully the way
because we can do loads of stuff in
destiny 2 like compared to d1
yes um on the platforms and
looking for like not to be too much a
cakewalk as well
well what people know how to do the raid
like i don't want it to be like
a pure proper speed run for his first
race
30 minutes crap yeah like speedrunners
just go and zoom through
like bypassing it because they've got
the knowledge out to the encounters
uh obviously once the challenge the
whole challenge mechanic kicks in that's
pretty interesting though
and the only thing i wondered for that
was is it going to be
a checklist that you can see like
complete this is what you need to do
or is it going to be is that going to be
a blind factor
that's what i'm kind of curious for um
so that that that on its own if it's
blind then that could be interesting
if it's a checklist then it's there for
you to do and you know what you need to
do
and that again is what i'm intrigued i
prefer
i would prefer to be blind so you've got
to be working out to do
even if it gives you just a small clue
as to what to do
and i'm super excited for all the weapon
drops coming back everyone that knows me
knows that i love fatebringer it's my
favorite gun in the franchise
outside everyone that is and um
getting that back in my loadout it's
going to be amazing fun although it's
going to be that or chaperone and i'm
like
yeah you got to go you can use both you
know equip them both you're good to go
there you go um other than that i'm
excited
i'm i'm going to avoid the boots my time
off i'm going to give it i'm going to
give it a bash
i don't sense a world first for myself
yet but i'd love to give it my best shot
and we got to see if maybe the ninja and
i might actually play that one
so it would be it would be in respect to
my co-host and probably about 150
episodes later to join him for the foray
back into the vault of glass so we'll
see if we can make that happen
original teams i don't i don't know if
i'd ever play fetch my original team
like guys i'm going on with it you know
i've gone on to bigger and better people
[Laughter]
i love it i love
[Laughter]
no that's like i think you're kind of
where i'm at on it too it's like i'm
curious to see i know the contest will
be 1300
do you guys think challenge 100 will
still be 1300 like
cap just maybe more difficult or more
mechanic based
like do you think they'll level people
up or do you think it's just going to be
more of the triumph
challenges and the mechanics to it i get
the sense
i feel like more mechanics you know say
more more things they've got to add
things to it
like pigeon said i mean you know why
vernon champion what
i know right they can check oh wow that
would be crazy that would be crazy
oh you know i said you got the girl
guard and all that stuff so oh there
goes bob absolutely so um
yeah like the whole thing is for me
challenges i want to see how they
implement um you know champions and
things of that nature because you figure
that's kind of good because
at the end of the day destiny 2
guardians
are too powerful for fault to glass in
its original
state like it would be a massacre we
would
mop the floor with all the new powers
you know i'm just thinking about well
the radiance everywhere i'm just
thinking about all this stuff
stasis even right like there's a lot of
stuff that you could do to really
control stuff so i'm very curious
um mechanically what they add i think
that's bigger then
the thing for me is the challenges right
the challenges in reference to
you know this tempos thing and and like
pigeon was saying like
it would be cool if you don't see it
visually right and everyone's having a
i think what's interesting is the whole
team will wipe
if you don't get it that's it that's a
different
kind of thing and and the last thing
yeah 1300 power
was was a cool thing because it's like
everybody gets in
there's usually that thing where it's
like all right man you know new
expansion
we got to grind y'all we got to grind we
got to get the level up we got to do all
this stuff
no saturday for the most engagement it's
it's more everyone's going to qualify
and it makes sense it's a nostalgic raid
and the last thing i think
is which i'm not surprised i know i saw
some people were a little mad i think
taz was a little bad about this but
i'm about to like like some people
wanted like this interwoven story
of a vlog and they were like it's going
to be self-contained and i had a feeling
it's almost like you know dusted off for
ocd
they're not going to yeah you put the
remixes old mixtape or whatever you know
like you're not they're not going to
write this elaborate story try to weave
this in because me and you said this
like how would they even do the initial
encounter around the world so
you know when you start up you build the
spire yeah that's still going to be
there
yes but not in like an open place yeah
yeah you won't be able to
patrol venus they said it's going to be
kind of an instance off area
i will be happy to see that sandbox
again i love the blue lava volcano i
miss that
so that's cool um but it is going to be
basically i'm picturing just this like
you know kind of cone straight into the
entrance area you've got the little
opening you'll run up you'll have the
platforms that you got to take care of
and then go inside so yeah i'll be kind
of curious how they handled that
uh one person on my chat did ask do you
guys think this will be
free to play or do you think it's
seasoned content
i was going to say that iceland could be
free and it would be nice if it was
yeah i think based on the light level
alone that sounds like it's
a free play thing yeah that people can
log
in and play and it's a read for them to
play for free
um so also i'll go down that whole path
of saying it's technically not
new content oh no yeah
so i'm not i'm not the way open that
kind of worms with chat and that but
like yeah
i i think i'll be free to play for all i
think that would be
a big selling point for uh picking up
the game
at least it would be a nice gesture
considering
you know other things they're making the
giant elephant turd still stinking up
the corner of the room
yeah yeah yeah yeah and as much as i you
know
i talked to me and you talked offline
about this as much as i love
that this is coming back for the class i
just felt it was interesting
you know after the week that we had last
week regarding transmog and
no mention you know i gotta say this
because even i love bungie you know i'm
saying
you know i love it i love this game but
you know
it's hard because vaulted glass is like
my most beloved
you as he calls me the rose tinted
glasses with this thing
you know this is the thing that got me
in the destiny made me commit the
destiny i have an emotional connection
there's no doubt
right and i'm excited for this the only
thing is
i i just want the community which i'm
already aware you guys are cognizant is
that
we love that we're getting this right
but let's not forget hold the line
on transmog let's not forget that they
did
not answer or address any of the uproar
the community had
last week and that to me is a problem so
it's almost like oh
shiny squirrel remember this remember
this remember how we
just jerk you over like like
hold the line on trash ball now granted
um what you call it dylan dmg yeah they
said something
they made a small look not in the club
a small little statement that was like
look you know we didn't feel it was in
time but you know
acknowledge whatever i just want to see
that addressed you know what i'm saying
because
we can't get distracted by this amazing
thing that they never
to make us forget about the pain that
they put us through last week
so hold the line guardians that's all
i'm saying but we get it we can't enjoy
this moment it seems cool
to your overall question i would hope
it's free to play i would hope
that more i was like so there's not one
right now is there there's not a free
raid they're all
yeah yeah and like pigeon made a good
point
this is technically not new content yeah
no it's not new
i don't if if that's an argument you're
having with anybody it's not new it's
seven years old the belt can prove that
because it's silver
and not gold and it's got the first raid
team on there from seven years ago which
is cool
so you give prime guard their little
shout out and then you'll get your new
clan name up there
but yeah it's like even this is like hey
this is the second time through we're
gonna
we're gonna you know polish it up a
little bit but it's still it's
it's vault it's been around for a minute
as you said you've done vault recently
in d1 now i am one thing i'm very
curious about that triumph list as you
said
i'm hoping they're hidden
but also i'm hoping because
shout out to my chat and stuff like that
they can find a lot of data mine stuff i
knew the entire
seasonal challenge every single triumph
in there
when the season launched right so
if that list leaks people are gonna go
back and play d1 trying to figure out
some of the ideas of what they can do
to get a leg up so i'm hoping like i
would much rather have like a patch like
saturday at like 9 30 one of those
things to like put it in the game
or activate it or something so people
can't look at it i don't want that
so i'm hoping as you guys like hope the
challenges are hidden
as well as they can be that's my whole
part absolutely
absolutely yeah i mean like i said but
uh we got that we got challengeable
we'll see what happens i am curious last
time i was curious on
just the look you know just with an
updated engine
you know oh yeah how it's gonna look in
d2 i'm very
curious to see you know graphically and
stuff like that and i've seen it like
like
i said the drops man you know when fake
friggin drops for a lot of people
the the fields are gonna come right back
you know obviously
all the other cool weapons we want to
see about that mythic class right if
that meant the class
it's going to be yeah yeah you kind of
feel like it has to be there
all of that that's a big we've had so
many people come on the last word
and talk about those drops and what it
meant to them and stuff like that so
it's could it be curious to see
those weapons into the sandbox and d2
standards so i'm excited
yeah well so vog for sure
should be fun should be good cog and i
might even check that one out might have
to stream that one
yes uh sandbox i feel like this is just
literally your twab so
sandbox is also your gym this is your
twab so
yeah i'm gonna cover like the high level
stuff and then you can go through the
detail
so first thing they wanted to talk about
was heavy weapons and they said they
have three roles there's ad clearing
single target damage and burst damage
okay makes sense they do different
things
swords they're like you know they're
ammo efficient for add clear single
target sustained damage secondary burst
damage at the cost of being next to a
dangerous target rocket launchers burst
damage or add clear secondary
machine guns ammo efficient add clear
secondary
single target sustained damage bullet
point we expect to adjust machine guns
in a future season they're not currently
hitting this target no kidding
you knock them down and they're still
sitting low so please get on this faster
anyways i don't have to i'll go through
a little of this
linear fusion rifles single targets the
same damage they're getting some
discussion so we'll get to them
drum grenade launchers burst ad clear
single target damage
exotic snipers also need some love
single target sustained damage where the
target has a handy crit spot
they go through a couple examples if you
guys want to know how they use stuff in
testing
read them you've probably tried all of
these
i did want to talk to you guys before we
get to the specifics though the balance
philosophy because we've talked about
this a little bit on here engine with
the sub
man the guests have been live on stream
shout out
with the big heart i'm terrible at this
whole heart thing there
there you go um they have two approaches
and i wanted to talk about this with you
guys because we can go through details
of how perks work
this one i sat there like with stream
yesterday just like scratching my head
so you got big swings
make a big change that we believe will
be immediately it will immediately
encourage new player behavior
most useful when we need to buff or nerf
something hard enough that everyone can
tell that it happened
the expectation that we may need to dial
the tuning in later in a related later
release examples the 120 hand cannon
buff and beyond light or the rocket
launcher buff in season of the chosen
incremental changes take something that
we feel isn't far from where it needs to
be
and nudge it a little at a time and most
useful when we don't want to over
correct or make something overpowered
or we don't want to make a change with
huge test weight
and would prefer smaller safer changes
examples the precision auto rifle change
outlined below
and the season of arrival's high impact
pulse rifle change
so we have seen examples of this they've
truly mentioned like the precision auto
change it's bumping up by like one
number
but then we also see everybody talks
about rocket launchers for like two
years and then we get 30 percent
so i wanted to ask you guys because i
was sitting there going it's like okay
everybody's like hey rockets rockets hey
how about rockets rockets need a buff
hey rockets rockets
30 here you go and like somewhere over
the course of that time
wouldn't it be easier to be like okay
everybody talks about rockets let's give
them like 10
see how it goes and my question to you
guys is
do you think that they use the big
swings to
shift to the meta intentionally or do
you think they honestly
save the bigger swings to get players to
feel it more
because if they slowly bumped up rocket
damage over the course of like nine
months and three seasons they would be
like
oh these actually kind of do feel better
but it like so gradually got there they
don't feel it i wonder what you guys
think their philosophy is
if they intentionally want to like hey
swords are getting a lie well let's
knock those down and bring the rockets
up or is it more
we want to make things impactful when we
put them in because if it's like we
slowly bump rockets up five percent
every month
nobody's going to nobody's going to care
i've got stuff to say but i want to be
respectful to our guests you sir
thoughts
uh i do have a few thoughts um
a big factor on that i think is the
content that they create
um i'm gonna reference like the
reckoning i don't know if everyone's
done the recording oh yeah
oh yeah um it was it was a great example
of like too much power creep
and like at that matter at that point in
time too much power keep too much tuning
overturning et cetera et cetera
for those that don't know the record was
uh like a pv event
involved going up a bridge shooting lots
to take in
lots of big yellow bars and stuff but it
was such a cake walk for our abilities
and our loadouts at the time
that the only way that they could design
the content
was to have things push you off the
bridge
so snipe you from a distance like yeah
so fast forward to just now if they're
putting out they're putting out a glass
and and i think they're going to buff
and change stuff
in line with that coming out so that it
becomes a
an experience that's still enjoyable but
not a cake walk
and that's before and after contest as
well um
i'm trying i'm just trying to articulate
this here sure uh as far as the changes
go i think
some of it's planned for the content
they're releasing they'll turn around
and say right here's the new pv event
i we think this this well they've
designed it based on the current sandbox
and then they might find out later that
those exploits and stuff
and that's when they'll do a big maybe a
big sort of jet reaction
change stuff like the 30 off the rockets
but then as well as that
i don't i just don't know ma'am it's
such a tricky game a lot of it's data
balancing like
who's using what i mean i've seen a lot
of reactions for one of the
the changes to maida i don't know if
you're going to mention that in a second
but
people are like yeah we want these
changes in pvp but
they're changing the mind the catalyst
um i don't know i really don't mind i
think
it's great getting new sandbox changes
the big the big changes that make you go
oh that's meta now the only thing for me
as a player though is
like i don't know how long to keep hold
of
a drop i could go that's an okay drop
but it's not matter right now
yeah i'm a big i'm a big fault holder
this has been a big discussion in my
community recently right here
horrible horrible i'm i'm living through
my
postmaster and character slots
constantly yeah that's bad so like a big
thing
is like retaining loadouts and stuff as
well
uh because they're not getting touched
until they're made meta
yeah and so honestly i don't know
answers properly
it's great that they change stuff i
don't know i don't know what their
overall philosophy is i do think
what content they're putting out has a
big factor on
how they change the sandbox for all the
weapons especially
um because i don't you guys also
remember like sleeper simulink got a
random nerf because
it was apparently going to be busted for
the the raid boss and garden
and i never to this day you know what
that personal
yeah so um
i don't know it's a tough one i like
incremental changes
it's just as long as they can react fast
and i think they're having a bit more
agile
with their changes um but the sort the
the short the small changes are
definitely um
to address like sudden feedback
for sure so but the big changes no idea
man that's
that's team try to change how you play i
don't know when and what they decide i
mean they've already
i liked this and that's why but they did
say we've got these other things going
to have a big change soon like the lmgs
and whatnot um but we'll soon see what
it is
sometimes it does feel like if you see
one side of the community asking for
insert change here but they come out
with a totally random thing
so yeah i see why you're asking i hope
that answers that in a way
um that's how i look at it that's what
they're doing but i don't know
the total reasoning behind it yeah
it's a good question before i answer the
question easy guy is um
i've waited a long time for this day you
know
my infamous my favorite my
baby one of my favorite even during the
galahorn
days when people were yelling galahorn i
was yelling
sleepers lipa simulant
was my baby i remember when people
laughed at it and i was like bro this
thing is
it hits like a truck i'm telling you you
know what i mean like
i brought sleeper in there i had so much
fun like sleeper and then
what really hurt is when d2 and sleeper
comes back and it would it had
for had a brief run you had the
reflective stuff all that good stuff
but you know it got a subsequent multi
nerfs and i blame that evil gambit mode
that he can killed my baby so that he
was so frustrated and i get it you know
the invader would come through look for
whatever and sleep with that per i get
it they had to handle it
you know and then we had the reflection
nerf it was just nerf
after nerf after nerf and then what made
it what shout out to the cops going
to see that they don't agree either
they're passionate that's right but what
made it worse was that
in d2 acquiring sleeper
and that catalyst is one of the
brutalist grinds
ever you gotta do whisper you gotta do
all these things to get this catalyst
and then what you get you still gotta
unlock the catalyst and then you got
that what is it it was the raid
just to get the catalyst and the random
it was brutal
getting this right and again to have
this thing
probably come back to see linear fusions
but shout out to rick hackers he out
here doing the lord's work
i got to shout out to homie rick cactus
he's been on he's been up on the
campfire many times you know he is like
when
are linear fusions getting a buff i've
been sitting on it
since um crap the crow remember that uh
what's the activity that we used to do
with the crow the hunts right and
they had some good they had a good
lydian fusion in there but it's like yo
near futures are never good right and
like i forgot the name of it yeah it
might be
the legit the linear fusion in there is
pretty good it's a legendary one but
again just that
linears are so garbage that you just
threw it in the vault
so it was one of those situations i just
kept things that i felt okay this had a
good role whatever
so i'm glad to see them finally
address lineage getting to the
philosophy thing what he's talking about
i see your point
or opinion in reference to i do think
part of it
has to do with the upcoming uh
weapons that they plan on introducing
right for the next season
i this is my fault i think their
reasoning is this and i
with the big swings i think with big
swings they tend to do
archetypes more so they'll look at an
entire archetype and like okay you know
what rockets are not doing it
or i remember when grenade launches
finally came up we were like oh my god
grenade
grenade launchers used to be a joke in
the heavy slot i remember at one time
you know that was that so i think that's
what because
like they even they even actually say it
they say they they believed it to
immediately encourage
new player behavior so this is literally
it incremental my guess with them
e is sometimes
specific weapons you know what i'm
saying
i think a lot of times they're like okay
we don't want to just bash this into the
ground
or you know what i mean so we'll just
take a little you know you get the
point one percent here you know you're
gonna say something you might say
no no like pigeon and i are messing with
each other in chat oh they're trying
to go through so um basically it's one
of those things where just like you know
i think
just like little changed i know they're
doing the uh precision auto rifle stuff
like that that's an archetype but
for the most part i think like exotic
weapons or is that like sometimes it's
like a very
incremental i i give them credit for at
least explaining
the thought process because that was
something i always wanted to do but i'm
gonna give it back to you eli
you know what do you feel about big
swing
versus increment i don't think this is
always one of those times where i just
want to be a fly on the wall
i want to understand like hey the whole
world wants rockets yeah we're still
waiting what about rockets no
no rockets no maybe and then it's like
that's one of those prime examples
because it got talked about so long like
rockets are just trash
they were bad for so so long and then
finally it's like how much you gonna
give them
about a third more damage you're like
seriously okay those are gonna talk now
but why did we wait so long to get there
that's one of those literal like if
rockets are all mostly that bad
and they're worried about and they're
worried about overdoing it well as they
said
try it smaller and then so what takes so
long for them to settle and then again
we get to another thing where it's like
how much time
in do they have to test archetypes
because then they mention like machine
guns is that going to take all of season
14 which could be
three to six months just to get because
it's like in a future season i'm like
it's gonna take you three to six months
to figure out if machine guns are not
strong enough
yeah we're about to make linear fusions
stronger rockets are better grenades are
decent swords
well those got crapped on uh twice so
it's like
it's weird because it feels like most
the community can
understand where things probably ought
to be and then when they get there later
i'm like
what's up guys what you doing and i know
they're so data driven there's something
i don't know but that's the stuff like i
wish we could know
like why did rockets take 18 months yeah
when you could be like hey 10 gonna hurt
anything
no probably not in fairness to you i
have to agree because
normally you know i'm very nice with
development but
with archetype like especially lenny if
you okay you don't like sleeping
simulink fine
but we know the entire linear fusion or
when you
laugh you roll your eyes when that
dropped yeah you're
like come on this is this is straight
line in the sand back in
season of dawn that one never got to
shine it's already sunset
and like that all the dawn weapons were
still cool but that one was like
cool i got one i headed my vault
i headed my vault until i deleted it
until i got sunset and i'm like what
what what
that long like that's a long ass time
do you know what i think adds to that
that the bonus and that's
what we're just saying chat there but
when lioness sign came out
it was had unique as hell perks it had
the fire in line like that you don't see
that often
yeah it's not it's a it's a very stock
pair
and the other thing was yeah the focused
farm for it as well
yes so the the play loop was
you focus farm for something that had a
lot of potential but never got to shine
but it's now that well you've got a
focus farm again for the linear fusion
in the game
and it's about to shine but as sad that
you've had to do it twice again that's
uh like a deliver from sunsetting yeah
but i think that's what adds to that you
you get all these amazing things with
unique perks that don't get to sign as
well
yep until they're buffed um i
myself i was combing over my fault last
night just looking at stuff going
that's going to be good that's going to
be good like i've got for example i've
got a dire promise it's got osmosis on
it
that's a hand cannon a 140 hand cannon
and it's gonna
well i meant i wonder what the stasis
effect is going to be sorry i know
you've not covered that no no no no
that's good yeah we'll get there but
like a bit
foreshadowing i think i wonder what
that's going to do
but up until now i would never have used
it so
it goes back in that it's not shown yet
and it's not a reason to
same thing with elemental capacitor same
way with uh stasis because you've got
the
like ads strafe like less of a penalty
i'm like you literally just gave
somebody a mobility stat by doing that
and that's something a whole lot of
people like that ads mobility
and if you're gonna give them that with
elemental capacitor i'm like on stasis
which is already powerful i'm like
i know that's not gonna be game breaking
but somebody's gonna be like
crazy unable to touch like strafing like
like back and forth like crazy so no
yeah that stuff's interesting but it's
like
yeah the some of the stuff takes so long
and that's why i wonder it's like
some of the changes i feel have to be a
little intentional sometimes
because like then they can get this like
rotation of what's good in this kind of
moving cycle of like oh we're coming
back around to linear fusion's being
good
and then they're slowly gonna get nerfed
like the one that i'm gonna laugh at
if they ever nerf rockets again i'm
going to be like guys
then you're showing your hand yeah they
take two years to
buff them and they're like well rockets
are strong now we did it a little too
much we're gonna have to bring them
over yeah yeah yeah i'm like you took
two years to figure out a number and
then you think you went too far like
don't do that
so that's kind of the point of like yeah
so it's just it's it was just a weird
philosophical one i was sitting there
with chat when i was reading through it
and i'm like
i have some questions so i wanted to ask
you guys
um weapon archetypes we've got three
main changes and then a question i have
for you guys as well
precision autos this is the incremental
they're taking precision auto so 450 so
you've got shadow price
you've got seven serif carbine those are
the two that i know of at least
um those are going from 17 to 18. so
we'll see how that fares in pvp nothing
crazy i think over the top i don't know
if that's gonna like
new meta but probably not um so you'll
be okay
autos won't be running running you know
cognito's gonna be fine
no crazy auto run uh quick touch on
fusions i think this is probably to help
counter shotguns uh they're increasing
the damage fall off
start distance by two meters so they're
just pushing out
the max damage a little bit farther um
linear fusions the main thing is they
have seen the discussion
that some people almost want these to be
specials
and then they kind of have to go back
and forth because we've seen arbalest
and to make that compete with like
sniper insta kills you have a charge
time so the aim assist on our list was
like hey here's half your screen are you
in there you're dead
like it was a bit over the top and
they're like i gotta reel that one back
in but how long did that take to get
reeled back in again as well
that took a long time yeah there were
they're like they're
they've heard the feedback of possibly
linear fusions being specials which i
think would be an interesting shift
for now they're going to keep in heavy
they're going to do precision damage 15
percent
which i don't know if that's enough it's
not bad but i still don't know what
if it's enough because i'd have to go
back and watch like error he did testing
like
he had a frenzy new linear fusion rifle
and he's like still doesn't hold up
so i don't know if 15 will be enough 20
percent on my air reserves ammo reserves
that's what i think that's not bad yeah
i think i think what it is is
i actually don't mind this one because i
was like
you have to the weapon i feel the spirit
of the weapon is to get precision crits
with it right
so you want to increase that reward that
not just
up the damn because i know them you know
bungie don't like shooting from a
distance
and people getting reported so they're
like okay make it a skilled weapon you
give them 50
i love that but the reserve ammo is
going to be key i think when we put on
those linear fusion reserves mods
and we get more chances at it
then it's going to shine in the long
game dps
and yeah i'm feeling good about this one
i'm sounds like all right this one
this is my baby i love this archetype
you know what i mean and when they
introduce you so
and to their point with the um yeah and
just to confirm for everyone exotics
sleeper and queen breaker also get these
buffs yes babe
yes baby oh those two queen break is
criminally underrated too but um
yeah man i think i think that this is a
nice play i think it will play that i
actually don't mind that they said
they're not going to move it into
special you know what i'm saying
so yeah i'm good with it man i i i want
to see how that rocket and all those the
uh what you call it when the 450s
needed love especially for pve 360s do
too and they're still not touched so
yeah
360 we already know three high impacts
so like like i'm just sitting here dying
anyway
uh before i get to my question about the
rares any are you good with this pidge
do you think there's more you need less
you need feeling good on this stuff
and i only had one thought and it's
actually
to do with how we use the weapons again
and it's when you're in activities
except for high like high-end stuff like
gms most stuff
in the game is just meltable you just
melt them
so something i miss that that happens in
d1 when you especially when you do the
raids is
proper hardcore damage phases where
you complete the running mechanics you
get a damaged phase but you should as
heck don't
like take down the boss on that damage
phase you have to go
over at least two more times oh the
check to damage
yeah damage check yeah so like we did a
wrap
maybe last weekend there on the easiest
mode because we were teaching someone
we still had to do three damage cycles
with all our particular loadouts most of
them were using things like sleeper
people were using dart drinker which was
the meta for the axis fight
and you still have to rephase it so i
think
when they're talking about the design
concepts for weapons and all the sandbox
changes
i think it'd be really cool to see
proper
scenarios for each gun is shine so burst
damage
and then like long long phases the long
phase and then like insta
kill damages so when you're facing
champions you already taking the downs
as fast as possible great when you're
facing the end a strike boss
you do it him down fast but also it's
damage checks like i'm not i'm not
vouching for damage decks we love
a boss mountain destination but when it
comes to doing raids and stuff
i i'm a big fan of doing that whole
endurance style playing the game and
then having the weapons that shine
through for those
unique damage phases i hope that makes
sense yeah i mean for sure
like linear fusions fit well for atheon
for a prime example actually
because you have a crit spot as opposed
to a tracks
not not a tracks wrong raid which one
uh secret rest
what you just
yeah so you feel like you've got
different places so as you said it'd
just be nice to see different encounters
like even a strike where it's not here's
a little room dude runs in a circle like
where's where you gotta you know have a
longer range shot at some point where
different people have different purposes
i get you yeah i
completely understand it'd be nice to
have heavies all have a reason and right
now
same thing with like heavy snipers i
haven't seen those used in a long time
yeah i love whispering darcy i remember
doing uh what was the the second red
layer
um yep yeah loved using
i i think darcy was a staple for me for
that raid because it was a big static
boss
it was really fun to offload darcy
rounds and sleeper rounds obviously
sleeper with f
not a sleeper sorry uh whisper
they they've not they've not been in the
meta for a while for pve
they're just kind of there like an okay
option
and it was another a boss that says hey
this is a great choice for this
this trade boss right that's totally
fine i mean look what they did with
tanix they made him a non-startable
close-range dps boss
and what we have in our loadouts we had
slog shotguns which had just got above
so i uh like i'm always savvy for what's
up and coming
in pve meta so i've already got my
threaded needles with orpool all loading
like
anybody all the good stuff um
so i think it's it's just a matter of
being savvy with what's coming up like
saying yourself that's going to be me
and next season or it's got a chance to
be meta like you said 15
isn't a lot but it could be enough to be
part of a dps build
like as an aggies linear fusion
something else
so yeah that would be nice it would be
nice man i'm excited i'm definitely
going to dust off
the i think it's called corsair's wrath
yeah somebody mentioned it in chat
earlier yep
one you know i've got a couple the um
the one from um
the the new battlegrounds i got like a
i got a couple sick rolls that i've just
been sitting on i just been vaulting
them because
part of me was like you know what you
never know
with bungie it's good i got i got a
couple frenzy ones with that too so
yeah being interested to see you know
now what the 15
you know what you call it how it's gonna
play out you know
in the dps phases and stuff like that
and that there's actually one boss in
particular
i can't one raid boss in particular i
want to go back to it it's a
garden i want to go back to garden and
see how linear is do there when you you
know you guys that floats up
megatron boss i would i want to get him
out of this so
we'll see you know we'll see how lydia's
playing but this is good i
you know at the end of the day i mean i
agree with e it takes too damn long
sometimes
but you know look it finally the day has
arrived i can finally
stop complaining this this one was for
me they they wanted to shut me up they
knew i was bad with trans ball so they
they gave me
my linear yeah fusions i just throw an
extra thing into the ring
um well in tandem with all that stuff
not to overlook is the the seasonal mods
as well there could be a nice port
there could be a nice portal on your
fusion mods to go in and hand with that
stuff
don't say that don't say that you
touching my heart yeah that's my
brother brother if i see some some lydia
or something with with unstoppable
or something bruh i would get excited
that would that would be their first
time on a heavy though actually yeah
i've never seen yeah
yeah maybe maybe the seasonal
exotic season pass exotic is a linear
fusion rifle
see now uh see y'all touching the fields
it feels right we're touching cognito in
a special place no i'm sorry
sleep again you're going too far but i'm
with it
sleep again man oh man i just love
that archetype i thought it was a cool
archetype you know because you know this
i know it is i'm not a sniper i'm i'm
trash at sniping
so lydia was for me literally they
smelled little amethyst
little charged stuff assistant put him
in the corner
uh so let's see let's see i i am i'm
curious to see what they do with that
artifact good point paige good point
cause uh
the artifact will be interesting right
yeah i gotta be excited again i was all
mad about this game
uh before we get into perks which is a
discussion in itself i want to check
with pidgin on your
perspective i wanted to see how you're
doing
so something good came up so i am free
to continue as long as
you let us know so what did this seem
like a decent break point
sandbox talk yes all right
so perks we actually get a decent amount
of changes
i feel like this has been quite a while
since we've had
a list like this of just weapon perks to
go through so this is actually
this is big so first one i'm kind of
pumped on this one actually
because it's one that i enjoy let's go
subsistence
when we made this perk we were
experimenting experimenting with unusual
downsides for perks but
check your focus uh but ultimately
decided it fixed
uh that reducing reserves wasn't an
interesting trade-off i i hated it
unlike especially if you get it on a
submachine gun oh
awful trash
i didn't even give a shot i'm like i was
like rubbish
yeah i know i mean it really was i have
a subsistence
rampage gnawing hunger that was
fantastic like i used that thing
in prophecy honestly and that's probably
used on a solar run but man you get on a
submachine guns
like or even a hand cannon you may as
well just yeah it was in the garbage
for sure uh we wanted to be able to put
the perk on special and heavy weapons
that part intrigued me i was like i'm
sorry what
where reducing reserves would feel
terrible which of course yeah that would
be pretty trash
some machine guns were granting a much
smaller magazine fraction
than auto rifles so no longer a reserve
reduction and smgs get 17 when you get
the kills like autos
it was 10 so that's gonna feel better in
general as well so
overall good changes i think here but
the one that has me intrigued is like is
this going to show up on specials and
heavies
that's a good question because i mean
that subsistence on like a
legendary machine gun would almost act
like um what is it overflow like 21
delirium almost because you're just that
would basically make the titan exotic
useless though but i guess it would give
you an option of how to play
they're definitely doing it look the
sentence we also wanted to be able to
put the perk or
special and heavy where reduced so they
they were thinking if once they put it
on especially
some assistance on breach load grenade
launchers in pvp yes
i'm just gonna i'm gonna piss everybody
off so
that would not they're not going to do
that that's a joke you never
know speed no that's not gonna uh uh
that's not gonna happen
that they won't do that i could see it
on machine guns i could see it even on
linear fusions is that something about
snipers and linears
to me those truly only come out for
bigger targets
i'm never gonna pop heads in pvp with
either of those for little red bars that
just
that feels like a waste of my ammo so
it's always like
oh what is it like triple tap on a not
on a sniper rifle
um where you have to get kills with a
sniper rifle i'm like never
no that's trash like some perks i know
they gotta like make the pool not always
god rules but some of them like just
give me better options
yeah subsistence i saw this one was like
sweet because i have a subsistence
frenzy roll right now i'm like hello
bro i got a subsistence um thresh roll
right now
that i love i get my super and then ski
yeah
it's good it's it's hot man i can't wait
smg's gonna be lit
any roles that you're looking forward to
pidge i'm just thinking
substance on a sniper rifle that's ammo
refills on kills that's like even
lower skill gap than triple tap and
fourth times charm
yeah that would be i now be obvious as
well or would just make those other two
perks
less useful obviously well for depends
on boss damage versus groups
i suppose now now i'm thinking the wrong
way here and
triple taps sustained damage nevermind
nevermind
as far as rules i might i'll keep an eye
out for
subsistence on an smg but i'm more of a
overflow guy or clash royale i quite
like
i think that's that suits my playstyle
better yeah
um i've got like the non-hunger
this was something i had from the the
reckoning and the rivals
and it's not getting sunset thank
goodness it rolls with overflow rampage
so i still think that's a very powerful
perk as opposed to subsistence but
subsistence
um is going to be really good in sort of
mid-tier
pve for sure as for special
weapons and stuff as long as they don't
do like what you're saying great slow
deeds that would just be
like you think in the game wild you've
got
you've got fighting line which it has
that effect where
if you clean up with another weapon it
reloads the weapon that's an exotic perk
and if you're going to say that
subsistence has that same effect all you
need to do is actually kill the target
that's scary does someone running right
just grenade launcher if you would
grenade won't enter in the face you know
yeah it'll be too much fine
yeah maybe would be a bit much but yeah
that's that's if they just wanna
that's one of those they just the joker
line they just want to watch the world
burn
so exactly next one hi
this is weird honestly i didn't even
know this high impact reserves and under
pressure due to technical constraints at
the time these were created
don't even get me started i know i had
the best new reds over there like engine
engine um
the trigger condition for on these prec
was for these is on projectile
impact basically it says the bonus won't
take effect until you fire the weapon
once uh but we have more flexibility in
perk activators now so now it should
activate even if the conditions are met
so high impact reserves under pressure
basically low end of the clip things now
finally work as intended as opposed to
have to
waste a bullet to activate it so
like a high impact sniper rifle means a
lot more than a high impact auto rifle
so this is working as intended which is
a good thing
um unrelenting this was hard to trigger
in difficult content
and health awarded was hard to perceive
so it now is easier to trigger in pve
immediate trigger on majors and heals 20
more so overall a little more
survivability there can we get a bungee
especially with these healing perks
and sorrows can we get an indicator on
the screen that says
yo unrelenting you know what i'm saying
active like
i just want to see because sometimes
you're in a mix of the combat you know
what i mean and you want to know if it
triggered you know what i mean
and i don't feel like the healing perks
especially cyril's like
i'm not really looking at the top of my
screen at that bar
all the time i would like to know that i
think they just need to add a little in
the bottom left
you know a little indicator with that
right in the middle of the screen healed
yeah i want to know i want to feel good
that it's working like
a little more obvious when stuff like
that kicks in
they always have to walk the balance and
they even talk about that later on on
one of the perks of like trying to not
overwhelm your screen with you already
got numbers you got the hood you got the
little kill feed down here in the bottom
left corner like
they're like if we add anything else
it's gonna get messy so it's tough but
i'm with you it's like
can you put like a little green healing
night like thing in the corner like
unrelenting like cut through make the
gun
light a color or something that to know
that it's activated because a lot of
times with these perks if
it may be working but it just feels
useless because it i don't
feel any type of feedback that you know
i'm saying like other perks would have
that'll say that you know it's going so
that that's my thing well i mean that's
the same reason why like reload and
damage number damage is
the most popular why exactly the most
easily
like tangible per se in a game video
tangible is not a real way to say that
but that's the most tangible thing you
can interact with
numbers go up animation goes faster like
it's very obvious it's happening as
opposed to
i think my health went up a little bit
was that recovery like yeah it's so
questionable it's not like
kill clip in the corner yeah rampage
times two rampage times three let me
give it a little unrelenting love that's
all you know feedback looks important
for the user
experience uh i i actually still use
sudos
and luckily got the catalyst and yeah
you're so right man you're in the middle
of it's mainly a crucible weapon you're
fighting someone
and you're about to die but you get the
pair to block and usually
you would just back out of the fight
anyway if you're almost done but at that
point in time you could have pushed
forward made a play
but yeah you you knew too late you you
see your health bars back like oh i
could uh
like came out on a streak there yeah
absolutely completely agree
there's a pop-up that shows when you
stagger and unstoppable yeah just stuff
like that
yeah just a little bit sympathetic
arsenal which is pretty much only i like
on a bow if you if anybody likes this
perk on any other weapon than a bow let
me know because i haven't found a great
love for it
um it isn't appealing enough for many
players it is but is useful in niche
situations
already yeah i know so we decided on a
small buff to sweeten it a little said
now grants plus 20 reload speed in
addition to its primary effects
the idea is when you reload your weapon
you reload your stowed weapons
on a bow you literally reload every time
right right
so faster reload on a bow i've got like
an archer's tempo
sympathetic arsenal i'm just going to be
like ready
switch go okay right so like that's
about the only place i can find a use
for it though it's like literally i can
only picture it on a bow
sdg and some sidearms okay so neuron's
got a couple examples just
if you burn through a clip basically is
the idea yeah pigeon how you feeling
about sympathetic arsenal
i i personally again i don't really use
it i mean
i think most weapons that would benefit
from that have auto loading on them
or equivalent uh don't get me wrong like
it's good to go into a fight with
everything loaded up to that extent
i mean i can see you going on a crucible
with a shotgun
and a ball perhaps and yeah
you're picking up ammo and then you know
anytime you built your shotgun there's a
good sense that's fully loaded you can
make a play and on that yes
though i think it's still super
situational and
not really going to change the game
especially when
yeah yeah shout out to durant he riding
for it he's like i'm telling y'all
get slept on you know what i gotta try i
i'm very disrespectful to that perk what
i
when i see that perk it's automatic
shard
i don't think i've even tried it to be
honestly the only thing i got it on was
about i was like
this has potential so it's like i put it
on it's like literally i was like fire
one thing i was like
totally reloaded at all i was like
that's not bad but i haven't had as many
uses for bows lately either so that's
kind of why
so now it's going to be a plus 20 reload
to the gun itself yep
and then okay yeah so you get a benefit
to what you're using outside of the
other ones as well so it's just all
about the remotes
mini outlaw plus you know kind of sort
of
whatever just wait did they say it's
when the pair activates or is it a flat
reload buff
on the weapon just like a plus 20 reload
so just like a
boost to the stat like especially a slow
reloading weapon little plus 20
you know and that's that's without
putting on a reload mod on your armor
yeah but you wouldn't want it on a
slow reloading weapon though because you
want the reload to go into effect for
the other things
to be full so you want this one on
something that reloads a little faster
you don't want this on like a machine
gun to wait like an hour to put all the
bullets in
finally cool now my other stuff's ready
i'm dead like
you want it somewhere else to reload the
machine gun for you that's the idea
i hear that rule right imagine not
having to take time to manually reload
xenophage or rock no i agree that with
those with the slow ones
it's gonna benefit if you have something
fast like what you're saying i i see
what y'all going with
reachload grenade launcher i don't think
it's on any of those though
dragonfly it has always bugged us that
dragonfly wouldn't proc on every enemy
you could finish with a precision hit
now it works on heavy shanks
conservators
okay a fun fact on that one i initially
read that as shanks
so i thought it meant the non-precision
shanks
and i thought that meant i could go in
and hit like red bar shanks and cause
like changes
i was i was about to tweet it out last
night and then one of my friends was
like
no it's precision on heavy oh thanks oh
i was like oh
i must read that i'm going down about my
fate but i'm
going boop on a single shank and it's
just going to work
yeah it's precision still so yeah
know i i i did the same thing i got too
excited
i was like the little red shanks gonna
get it
and then i was like oh not those damn
you know saying
since anything would it would have been
you're right anything the only thing i
don't like about dragonfly
i just wish the explosion was fast i
feel like there's that delay
and then poof occurs even faster than
after season the chosen fix
that's literally they're fixing the
speed of it so that's what i was like
because
that's my main thing i was like that
that delay would bother me
so i want to see how this now you know a
little quicker you know i want that sun
shot type of flare that just
poof like you know really really big
look at
hip fire grip i'm gonna leave this one
to the mercury's
the uh firing range chats i'm gonna read
just the first bullet point
and if you get confused from there it's
okay because trust me i'm
confused while i'm reading it hipfire
grip we're being careful not to over
buff this since hip fire is too
is too effective it changes the game
significantly so we're gonna bump this a
little bit
over the season of rivals above to make
it more useful option
here we go plus one degrees precision
hipfire angle threshold plus 1.2 x
reticle stickiness falloff distance if
you know what that stuff means more
power to you i have an idea what it's
basically saying
we can't complain we wanted the numbers
no you want to know the annoying part
no no there's they're they're like
half here's all the numbers in the world
and then down below
they don't even give me a number and
i'll get to that perk so i'm just like
what are you doing where's the
consistency
that reminds me see when they talk about
the oil right for the precise note rifle
buff they just give you a number and
it's not a reference to pvp or pv so
right
it's just a number i'm assuming it's pvp
it's
like that one is right but then that
stuff's like yeah
comes when we extreme technical stuff
they're like here's all the technical
jargon ever okay it's sorry it's for a
depth counterbalance there like
increases the recoil direction by how
much it doesn't say
like i'm just like you people anyway one
degree doesn't seem like that much but
for reference
hand cane and aim assist cone is 2.5
degrees at zero aim assist
to three degrees at 100 am assist
literally the full aim assist range is
half a degree
uh you can and you can feel the
difference between 90 aim assist and 100
aim assist on a hand cannon which is
0.05 degree increase
so a small difference can be significant
note the precision hip fire angle caps
at the aim downsized aim assist cone
angle
i'm eating my own words over here this
is rough there you go
i'll ask you guys uh that's our ironic
question
do you guys use the last ones incredible
i am so bad with that gun
i i'm terrible so this is for literally
the last word i'm sure
but i am awful with that gun oh no
do you just run up i used to i played on
console
it was amazing and when i by the time i
moved to pc they'd started nerfing on
mouse and keyboards
and it got the first nerf i used it for
a little bit but
it you can't do on pc with it because
you
you're such you're like a laser pointer
and yeah a lot that's relying on your
own accuracy but you lose bites that way
because it's hip fire
and then after the second time and it
was just gone um but
they changed the hip fire grip thing so
that could wait and again because it is
the aim assist that makes it so dominant
with
a controller on hand yeah um
yeah i watched a lot of grenada jake and
he still uses his last words
and you can see how it operates in the
game world you can just see
he's just we can do with it he can win
fights oh yeah um
so i'm hoping for that as that's one
thing that i've not used in 80s so
with these subtle changes like hoping
to see that gun shine a little bit
better or like
stand a chance again without being too
broken
right no i agree i think the last word
is definitely
gonna benefit i mean console like you
said it was
it's it's pretty strong with that aim
assist and now it hit fire which is
intrinsically how you're supposed to use
that gun at its most effectiveness like
this should benefit you know so yeah
good good call last word users dust them
off
get out there could be be a fun meta for
you
we're gonna see we're gonna see yeah
these favorite ones the iron
the eyes oh dude i went in on this in my
video god
i'll let you make the hell out of me
this is all you
whoever grip iron reach iron gaze
we are cautious we were cautious when
making stat bump perks in season of
arrivals
not wanting to break weapons that ranges
at too low a cost
but the penalties shipped with these
were too much now that we've seen them
in the wild
reduce the second stat penalty from
minus 40 to minus 30. it still sucks
i hate these i cannot stand these and
it's even worse on the adepts but like
i looked them up the only one that is
okay
is when you give up reload speed for
stability i think is one of those like i
think it's grip
but gaze or reach or one of those when
you're like hey let me get
plus 20 stability for minus 40 or still
minus 30 range i'm like no
no no way in hell anybody's picking that
right i can't stand these these are way
too dramatic
i think the they've got the new iron
barn weapons coming out
next season and i'm in interested
in a shotgun with iron reach or gaze the
one that gives you more range
i think that that that's the real yeah
like
it just i think it's going to depend on
the archetypes man like is this that
trade off worth it
still i don't know i remember i got a
hand cannon i got the
steady hand and i had the real loads
there like the
one you were talking about about this
that had the uh minus whatever reload
and that gun
already has a so it's just like negative
negative 40. it's like from reloading
that
he's like hold on i gotta make the guns
at the bullets and the animation he's
over here like
pressing the bullets okay i'm back five
minutes later i got my clip in
exactly so i think it really comes down
to archetypes man
because i've got the smg just now the
multi-mac and it's got
it's got the rain spark on it and i
think the penalty stability
yeah and because like on pc at least you
don't really feel it at all
so i guess that's subjective to the
platform as well
yeah but uh yeah that gives it really
good dueling range
like up to like 20 meters and you can
start spraying someone in the face
whereas if i had an smg that was that
without iron reach it wouldn't have the
same range stat
and i wouldn't really feel the benefits
of stability anyway
i don't feel so yeah i think that comes
down to archetypes as much as the perks
should just shut up and quit complaining
i think you're right i think they're
still less desirable perks as opposed to
the the staples
yeah um but i think if you look at you
can an archetype and say hey that would
actually benefit
from that that's when you start to like
a shotgun with stability
yeah you don't need that right yeah so
just give everything away if you'll give
me range people do that all day long so
that makes sense i didn't think about
what's coming so there's a couple
again niche situations where you're
going to go for it but sometimes i see
this i'm like oh this is just awful
i think one of them was an smg and the
range was like five
and i was like it was the multi-modal
i think i got that one hold on i
actually want to check them i think it
was like a multi-mock and it was
which i'm probably saying wrong in the
first place um
uh nope that was oh no that is it with
iron reach
um yeah so plus 18 range minus
stability so that one's not horrible but
i feel like there's some
yeah there we go i got iron gaze so
minus 31 range plus 20 aim assist
on a submachine gun
my range is 10.
so yeah no not so good
something she got is close encounter
anyway but i hate
but yeah so it's just it seems it'll be
30 so i guess a little give and take so
oh well i'll be quiet and shut up it's
fine are you good you're good
with you i want you i always felt that
this it's too hard to swing on the
opposite side
to for me you know obviously it's going
to be some guns in some specific
scenarios
where you know things may you know be
beneficial for a specific you know thing
but
i just hate it just doesn't feel good to
get a perk that says
we're gonna take away all of this with
this perk you know and i'm just it don't
feel good you know those things never
attract me but we got osmosis man big
one oh
yeah osmosis well elemental capacitor i
think has more but osmosis
this was a question osmosis now switches
the weapon to stasis damage when playing
a stasis subclass this should work for
any mechanics that ask for stasis damage
so basically is this just to do bounties
with stasis damage
because it's not going to do what i want
it to do where if i hit them six or
seven times they're frozen
that's not how that's going to work
that's what i want it to do eventually
yeah but do you guys think this is just
like oh now you can kill stuff with
stasis damage via bounties
is that all this is for probably all
right what'd you think is there anything
i'm missing
so this is like i say earlier i've got
that dire promise with osmosis
and does that mean when i got a pvp with
it that i throw a stasis grenade and i
start shoot someone else in the face
is it going to start stacking slow and
what on them
i don't think i wish it would let's just
say that i wish it would
because that's what i want like i want
solar to slowly build up like kuja's
done some cool stuff for like
possible future builds but i've always
wanted like right now we've talked about
its joke of a color match game
be like oh hit the orange guy with the
orange button hit the get the blue guy
with the blue thing
hit the dark blue guy with the blue
thing is the only thing i see coming
right now
green maybe next in which all these
things are just colors right now they
don't
do anything so if a weapon fire stace is
outside of that grenade launcher
if i have a stasis weapon it's just for
a color who cares but if i shoot stasis
weapon
and it starts to slow them down that
would be amazing
but i just don't know if it's going to
work that way and i doubt it highly yeah
damn well they ain't doing that right
that would be too fun oh that would be
so like if you could get an auto rifle
in pvp you hit somebody like four or
five they start burning and then you
could bail and they just burn out like
that would change the game and make it
oh that would probably break a lot of
things but i think it'd be a hell of a
lot of fun
sounds very obvious you got to stop
getting out right now it's all that fun
it's too much fun you have to get much
fun and now writers i'm sorry
back in line we're all this
on fire freezing toxic burning damage
yeah too many
too many things we're going to break
those legendaries yeah those legendaries
can't do too many perks we know that is
like stately settlements from rpgs the
effluent if they had to introduce that
to the stasis effect they would need to
have one for everything like an effect
of everything
it wouldn't just be only stasis does it
with moses
if anything they might have and they
might introduce
stasis shield breaks like you said right
season f at the minimum
but for pvp i i can just see it you log
in
start the season osmosis hand cannon pvp
you start shooting someone they get
slowed and you're just sitting like
uh-oh
like you know what exactly everyone's
gonna be tasting that was mostly okay
those rolls would be chased so hard oh
it would be so nice though too it's like
hey i'm in solar
you should not be able to freeze anyone
in their solar subclass with
with stasis i'm sorry but like i'm
literally fire
yeah i'm literally on fire be like no
i'm still gonna freeze you down i'm
literally burning through your fire your
ice right now
come on they come to you anyway
rant aside elemental capacitor with a
stasis subclass grants plus recoil
direction
again they don't tell you how much but
they'll give me the 0.50 degrees cone
angle
and reduces ads move speed now that one
i thought was actually interesting
because if you go stasis which is
already a powerful subclass and then you
give somebody a reduced ads move speed
penalty you just
bumped their mobility stat without
needing a mobility
like stat so that actually seems like it
has potential for people to like you
know strafing in their gunfights and
stuff like that
i think gotta say it ineffective you
know what i'm saying but um
cosmic eyes puts out cosmic fire
yeah it'll be look it they [ __ ]
back i see the chat shout out to uncle
donut xbox you know i'm saying yeah like
i agree with all of that i agree with
the fact that
you know like you said he mentally back
to the whole
thing like if you're in a fire solar
class you feel you should melt ice
it feels like it i just feel like it's
ice it's not affected by normal fire
that's based around
oxygen this is different stuff
yeah i don't know how else to explain it
because yeah it just pisses me off i
it's so annoying being like oh cold snap
graded i'm in my super runner now
i'm like this is super wrong oh dear
disrespectful
very damn uh yeah elemental capacitor
seems like it could be interesting to
see if people are just like you can't
touch me
can't you can't touch me like they're
just all over the place
uh no distractions because an exotic
change below
the sniper rifle flinch changes in
season of the chosen
want to make no destructions a more
appealing option for combat flinch they
reduce the trigger time
for it to activate by half a second and
increase the flinch reduction by a
whopping 5
doesn't sound like a ton but what do i
know mm-hmm
i mean try to make that for snipers you
know
more appealing i guess we'll see it's
one of those in
in use we gotta see yeah hilarity
embodiment
celerity and bottomless grief they
already covered this before
yeah same things that happen when you're
the last person alive but now it always
grants plus 20 handling plus 20 reload
for solarity
bottomless grief is plus 32 magazine
value not bullets remember that uh same
thing with thresh
it's already it's active in pvp now
somebody i think said this is a typo but
basically it works
in all the places it's supposed to now
um so were there any major standouts i
know we kind of talked about them is
there anything you guys read in there
like woohoo
or man anything in there that you guys
are excited for next season
uh when you're fusions again i'm excited
for that because it's
one of my favorite weapons to use uh i i
like i said i play the game i want to
place that's how
my fantasy of playing destiny is so even
though it's not been made i've been
using
linear fusions but it'll be good to know
that now they'll be meta
so that stands out for me uh i'm buzzing
for photographs i
i actually hang i was trying to wonder
if the the picture that they previewed
was
the cut from destiny 2's engine or if
that was an old
pca concept or something and other than
that i'm excited to take part in the
dates
and get a team together and all the good
stuff
and i think on top of that is the
ongoing discussion for vlog has been
some people haven't played it so it'd be
great to finally teach people who
haven't
and then some way down the line we've
got the cross play stuff coming up so
that would just
blow the doors wide open as well and i
know that wasn't mentioned in the web
i'm just thinking in terms of
teaching people reads and stuff and like
i mean in the middle
yeah absolutely yeah for me but you know
subsistence is huge that's a big uh
favorite of mine
you know especially now for smg i'm a
big smg now
like smg really leaves the kinetics a
lot for me lately that new one that's
good
yeah i love what is it extraordinary
rendition or whatever it is
i'm a huge fan of that i have another um
kind of god roll
of the um season of dawning sub machine
i've got the name of that one
um i you know gotta go what was that
sunset though
is it yep it might be
so worthy was the last one that made it
because we're keeping the war mine cell
stuff so yeah don is the last one to go
so we got that obviously linear fusion
i'm not going to go
announcing with that um dragonfly i want
to see
how that that goes in and i'm actually
gonna give um
what you call it a sympathetic awesome
one i'm gonna give it some love i'm
gonna try it
you gotta let me know if you find the
magic with that one yeah i wanna see
i'm gonna see what you know when it
comes up again i guess i'm more curious
if it shows up on different stuff
right that'll be the one yeah the new
weapons and then also
that's on a breach load you're going to
make people cry i'm going to laugh my
butt off but people are going to cry
i'm going to convince you if that oh my
god released i'm going to go back to you
i'm going to go
it was you i mean cog does this all the
time
i called sunsetting a week before it
happened so he's like can you stop
talking to bunji for the love of god
please just leave him alone
let him do their thing paige they listen
to a man i'm telling you i would be
surprised i wouldn't be surprised
and i'm curious to see like the weapons
that come out you know
how many of um you know are gonna
introduce
these perks and you know hopefully we'll
see if we get we stinking any new ones
but
yeah they're clearly setting up for the
meta you know they
clearly there's some weapons coming that
they got some things in mind
and i'm waiting to see how much they add
to the loop pool that's always my thing
like
been taken away but now how much have
you been adding and
i don't know if we talked about it a lot
on machine guns you know
oh that's one thing i wanted to say yeah
let's go
let's go rares i completely blew past
this in my video i made i was like what
the hell we added a rare machine gun
and bow to the world loot pool recently
but we didn't have any obtainable
linear fusion rifles or breach load
grenade launchers and wanted to make
sure these archetypes were easily
accessible
why they added existing unobtainable
rare linear fusion and breech grenade
launchers to the world
loot pool why are you putting blues in
the no
i read that and i'm going it has to be
for new players because
otherwise i want to jump out a window
yep i'm not gonna i miss the part where
i said blue
for those problems as well i think
that's just
i mean that's just a satisfied free play
player's new account it's gotta be not
like so they at least have an option
that
will come through the warlock out here
he blew past it and oh my god
i love that i love it oh yeah you guys
are you guys are on it
but no i've read i was reading this
first i read through the 12 with my chat
and i was like
all right i have some thoughts and then
i went through and recorded and i still
was like i
i don't get it so maybe it's new players
i don't know i just like but i'm like
wow
i just like why are we putting more
blues in i don't want to see blues ever
again
like ever so why
and i think honestly it's like okay so
we need to let we need a void machine
gun in case you need one
give me a legendary void machine gun
that has more perks and it's more fun
that's like i'm never going to take a
blue into a like grand master nightfall
to set
no no no that's not gonna happen so
what's the point
i don't understand the point so
but you're that you're that a brand new
account you've discovered the joys of
lfg
someone your team says have you got a
linear fusion rifle and you go let me
take my
math stuff and then you've got that nice
little blue linear fusion or with
us and then you pull it out you would
they inspect your inventory and they
boot you from the group
i've got my i've got my linear fusion
equipped is this a good one
uh you've been kicked from the party oh
oh yeah
you've been kicked i also want to shout
out all 450s man i think
you know dust off so far shadow price
should be late battle price should be
lit there
you should feel good about getting
worked so excited but we still don't
have one
i haven't done a ton of nightfalls but i
don't know i can't even tell i don't got
a pallet
i have one i have a couple palindromes
it took me a long time to get even a
palette i still don't have a swarm
between some of the awesome people in
the community they're like hey we gotta
drag you at least through like arms
dealer get you
some type of swarm because i do need one
of those so
no doubt we gotta get to these exotics
man no i know mods first this is again
where i was really annoyed
uh a depth mag and depth targeting same
reasoning as iron banner perks we were
cautious initially but think the f
think it's fine to reduce the penalties
on these perks for having them in action
reduce secondary stat penalty from -20
to -15 fix the depth mag to work on
swords
i'll just say the adept counterbalance
increase oil direction but recoil
direction benefit
by how much they're not gonna tell you
but the biggest thing i'm like the iron
banner i understand that's not an
in-game per se activity that kind of is
but it's really
not um in my opinion a depth
straight up should not have a negative
that's just my opinion you got to figure
out what you're going to do
to make it adapt to do what it's
supposed to do but it should not have a
drawback
if you go through the effort of either
the chest or a grand master i don't care
if people can farm them
it takes people like people like pigeon
and other people can farm and carry
people through them but the average
player
when they do a gm they're like holy crap
yeah i got one why is this kind of
negative on it like
that's that that's a feels bad and
yeah so from like a you know a heavy pve
guy
i don't know if you're a trials person
as well but i mean when you see
an adept mod that has a negative are you
okay with it do i overreact or what do
you think
i did i don't i don't think they're
overreacting to be honest but um
like i just don't use them i just go
that's going to give effect
i'm not going to use it i mean the big
discussion was about
like the initial trials weapons so i
asked for my trouser
i do dabble in trials i'm lucky enough
to know folk that
can help take me to the lighthouse every
now and then
and have worked up the mods and stuff
but
see when it comes to actually slotting
them in a weapon like
it's it comes down to what the best mods
are so if like pvp
you've still got normal icarus adept
icarus is one of the best ones because
it gives you
all benefits and that that's that's what
i expect from an adept mods not
detrimental stuff i mean
i i that's that plain simple i won't i
don't like seeing a negative start on my
weapon
any weapons i mean if anything
i could i would theorycraft what would
be a potential drop
that uh if i had an adept mod i want to
try to think an example say
a rocket launcher with a bit mag or
something or
um i'm trying to think an example
i would need to have all the stats in
place to accommodate for the detrimental
effect
and then even then it would be a very
specific set of perks
so i don't know man i don't use them
i don't like them i agree i mean that
right that's
if you don't and you're the one earning
them
that's sad that's me that's just not
what uh
not worth the effort especially with
this you know these end game activities
that they're giving these out
you know yeah it's it's not something
that you look forward to
and thus reduces incentive to do them
you know i mean if you want something
shiny you want something to feel
powerful
that you completed this hard task you
know and
yeah they got they got to fix it i i'm
with you i don't like those negative
parts i don't think you overacted at all
i don't like those negative perks at all
like i don't think they should be
in the game to be honest like what's the
purpose
i like like make the player feel good or
don't do it at all like
it's just the
that we more are when the storm came out
their depth big ones
mods yeah that i think that's great um a
mod that does multi functions
that's perfect that that's the direction
i'd love to see a bit mods go
it's it does what we've got but it does
it's slightly better
it doesn't have to be broken levels of
like
insane range boost or uh
stability booster whatever you're adding
to it just needs to be
a slight bit better or it does it
in a different way like imagine the
depth fusion where stability says it
tightens the spread or something that
makes it
it that i wouldn't say that was game
breaking it just
like the counterbalance stock it
specifically says tighter shot spread
rather than
it just being a stability related thing
that's just a suggestion i'm no game
designer obviously
i would but that's how i think the depth
module in the future
i agree i agree uh exotics
uh mida multitool uh we've seen many
requests to switch for this from
outlaw to something more useful one
thing we observed with mida is losing
fights the weapons that cause more
flinch so they're changing the catalyst
perk from
outlaw to no distractions thoughts
you intrigued what do you do
did you have a lot to say about this
edge
i said earlier it's so random man yeah
um
i i don't use my tomato too i don't know
who is in the mail
scouts aren't really that meta at all i
think outlaw was way better
for it because you're usually you tend
to get precision kills with it
right and yeah i guess
what they're saying is that it's a it's
literally losing fights
and i think the reason it's losing
fights is because flinch is so bad in
the game
as it is so i think
that's what they said with the buffet no
distractions earlier it's they're
doubling down on this
is how much flinch so now this perk will
actually bring you back to
that handle like manageable level um
and i've been there i've done that i've
been in plenty of fights where i get
flinched
and missed my shot and so
i can appreciate the perk but again on
on maida great but again going back to
earlier i don't think no distractions
there's a perk that will choose over
other staples at the moment
yeah yeah shout out to antarctic well i
scar time better
dmt yeah damn man's tail is out get
there in a second shout out to cool guy
though cool guy had a tweet yesterday he
said real talk
i see mida inserting itself in the meta
i really do always been a versatile
weapon now 0.9 ttk
boosted movement speed one second no
distraction activation
35 flinch reduction and can have two
unflinching mods
radar active wild ads 100 aim assist so
i mean if you listed off like that it
sounds pretty good
just have to see i still don't love
scouts but of scouts it it
it's reasonable it was yeah it was the
premiere
one you know what i'm saying scout for
his time so yeah we'll see i mean no
the what it is i think the cell is no
distraction in its
new form so yeah you know we shall see
if it really you know because i think
for for mida to shine
it's got to be able to handle uh 120s
from the distance
in my opinion you know what i mean and
bother snipers
right so if it's doing that then yeah it
could be effective and
you know i like scouts to kind of make a
comeback and i don't think the whole
archetype is but
mighty is suited you know hopefully to
shine so hopefully what cool guy's
saying
it would be nice i i i like you know
mighty to come back a little bit not to
get too crazy no
you know a little bit so we got that we
got the hawkmoon hawkmoon increased
priority of perot causal charge and
paracastle shot buff text basically they
said making sure it's staying on screen
so you can see it so it doesn't drop off
in the future sometime further into
season 14 i'm gonna go dead man's tale
first because i have a weird
thought about the other one with the
upcoming nerf to 120 hand cannon range
we expect to see a surge of dead man's
tail usage which is already high
we had enough moving pieces in season 14
that we didn't want to try and squeeze
this in at the time
but we have a change ready to go that
reigns in its ability to
challenge sniper rifles which i'm gonna
say something a second
120 hand cannons and scout rifles while
in hip fire without detracting from the
fantasy weapon
i am sorry but if a hip fire fill in
whatever word goes beyond that hip fire
anything
can challenge a sniper rifle no
that's just no in my book i'm sorry but
the whole point of a sniper rifle should
not be to get messed with by one of
those
you should at least have to be down the
iron sights to screw with a sniper rifle
i feel like i feel it
okay so that's me anyway thoughts
dead man's tale did not become a pain
point until
it started flooding the trials playlist
i feel it really got exposed
i think it was the dead cliffs weekend
and
multiple matches that i played was
people running up to the catwalk area
and it was either line rampant titans or
flying warlocks just hovering as high as
possible with dead man's tail out
and i just didn't know what to do me and
my team just
you would walk out in the lane and you'd
be like oh they're up there
not to manage that damage tram pops
insane every time they
see the time they've got like two taps
on you which ain't hard to hit
they just you just wait honestly and
don't get me wrong that's me
maybe using a 120 hand cannon still um
but it's really hard to fight against on
on stacks it becomes really noticeable
another thing about that conversation
interestingly and i'm glad it's actually
getting changed because
as far as i know console dead man still
isn't really
a pain point on there because not as
much at all
and i wonder why that i think it's
because you've got that easier hit fire
control on pc
unless things got just deadly accuracy
yeah
um what's the role pitch what's the role
people are using uh
if you know in pvp with demands or
they're using what
you know dude there's so many i think
top picks
for me at least was moving target and
i'm just not vorpal dead man still
because like
you cast a super against the dead man's
tail and already down
and you could take people out in three
or four taps including titans
yeah and get back in there and get some
more better roles
the seasonal the chosen seal
i've been getting my scannables in there
so i've got a couple of those
okay i was curious i was very curious
about that
interesting yeah i mean i'm with you on
that i mean he
you know that man is going to be out
here it's going to be out here for a
while you know
they said they they're going to look at
it you know what i'm saying but um
yeah for sure based on what you're
describing bridging
that sound pretty scary yeah we jumped
in there well so uh
yeah four pool all that stuff moving
target
all that stuff and then like you said
that damage ramp
up that's what really sets it apart so
yeah yeah they got to deal with that
like one
one or two credits in your weigh-in 800
to the head territory
which is mental at like 30 40 meters
yeah and don't get me wrong it's great
to see a scout rifle shine but i think
that's just
too low-risk high rewards at the moment
yeah so yeah when they just said hey we
want to reign in the hip fire grip
against sniper rifles i'm like excuse me
that's wrong if you're ads and you put
that little like iron sight on him and
you hit him
i get that no hip fire grip should hit
that far if a sniper is like
i'm thinking of is it convergence the
big one like pantheon from d1
yes long sniper if you're messing with
people on that map stop just
stop yep um
okay so here's the one that i read and i
was probably more confused when done
reading it
than when i started all shotguns
we don't expect the change to the two
dominant shotguns
bellwinders lie astral horizon replacing
quick draw with surplus that's the
change
and nerfing quick draw to really move
the needle on shotgun usage overall in
pvp
shocking still going to be there we
agree with some of the comments that
weapon usage is not only dependent on
tuning
but that map design is also a factor
what
however we want more weapons to be
viable on all maps
and we can achieve this through tuning
giving other special weapons more room
to excel
specifics coming later all they told me
is shotguns are still going to be around
and they're looking at special weapons
like
okay did you get anything out of this
oh hold on fusion rifles as with some
other changes we don't want to bump
these up too fast so we'll follow up if
needed
once again more nothing like but the
shotgun so
the question is like shotguns are still
going to be there they know quick drones
are there but again the way the maps are
designed they flat-set it
corridors and things unless you are on a
map like convergence of which you've
still got the higher tier
shotguns sliding behemoth shotgun
they're still very very prevalent
what's this is there no raising my hand
anyone interested i'm being respectful
i appreciate it um yeah um
out of maybe i'm looking into this maybe
i'm two rose colored glasses here
but i see the word matt mentioned twice
maps you know based on the maps viable
specifics coming later if i about
special weapon tuning not maps
there's not a map coming set next season
no we might get a back
then we might get some new cruisers no
no
no no don't even hope damn i'll keep
your expectations
keep those expectations at zero if it
goes up from there you can only win
no you don't even no don't even don't
don't think about it don't no it's not
worth your time it's not worth the
the heartbreak ugh well you know because
he said
they won't they want to be viable on all
maps you never know yeah the ones we
have not new ones
pidge thoughts on this whole weird
paragraph
look i'll go home i could dream as early
see when
you've read it back slowly enough like
it does sound like a paragraph it's just
like
over here they're just saying yeah
yeah shotguns are going with dormant
flip it yeah
we're going to try and get everything
working nicely
also map maps have a part to play and
these
i guess more of a statement in
information
it's not really it's not really giving
as much to go on
um me personally i'm a chaperoned man so
i can't wait to like wreck some people
that have been
heavily relying on uh quick drawing
stuff for quick shutdowns
yeah but the whole quite drawn their
thing as a conversation and so on
because i've got a lot of weapons in the
game that
have quick draw that aren't special
weapons and
they were pretty viable in that sense
yeah i did i think it's just a statement
they're just kind of
stainless is where the game's at so
these shotguns are going to be pretty
dominant by the way we think
i think they're just saying there will
come a time where they'll try and
make it even more balanced if it's still
a really bad outliers
so we'll see yeah chevrolet your shop
roll gonna be nice out here man
yeah it's definitely gonna be running
the table yeah
shout out to new rad who watched
somebody with chaperone in well of
radiance
map somebody from almost 30 meters
yeah he showed me the clip and about
lost my mind
i was like i'm sorry he just hit that
shot that's crazy that is an insane
combination it's probably not going to
come up all that often but yeah i was
like well
well luna faction sorry well luna
faction with chaperone
like almost 26 27 30 me it was some
stupid number and i was like
wow that's terrifying i may as well just
shut my game down at that point
i feel like you've been killed by
chaperone from halfway across the map
you've been disconnected
you got killed so hard your internet
died
yo 28 yeah 26 and a half meters is just
dumb
i was like that's crazy that's crazy
wow so there's a tip for you in a good
clip trying to work on getting that to
happen
yeah get it get it get a crazy crazy one
as for that we've got you know go for
the gold you got guard guardian games
some hot fixes
one thing the reactive pulse mod from
charged with light may no longer be
emitting a burst of damaging arc energy
that's literally what it's supposed to
do that's one of them
so like that's the only thing you got
some hot fixes and other stuff that are
in there which is fine but that was the
only one that's actually
functional everything else seems to be
cosmetic which is fine
um yeah last thing i wanted to say
obviously i know you still may have
other things to do but time wise
next week oh the bombs gonna drop
for whatever season of the redacted or
re season of redacted keep saying of the
is not there just seize your love
rejected trailer um there's been a rumor
about one thing like ripped off the
off the website of a name it's cool
but we may get into some like spoiler
rumor question mark probably
sorry now you're more than welcome to
um but there was a rumor of somebody
just basically
pulling data off the website season of
these
now some people like siva siva because
all that stuff's been going on twitter
splicers theoretically are fallen
scientists if you go into the lore
that's their main perk of
taking technology trying to figure out a
way to fall and use it but that can be
with anything so it's not specifically
siva related
but season of the splicer was the piece
of data which now
reads as xxx like they they grade it out
in the text so it was found and now it's
been
basically removed so
whether it is that or not two questions
one how long do you guys think next
season will be mostly for pigeon because
we've talked about this
and two uh icora is kind of coming into
next season do you have
any idea where the season could go
story-wise
and as far as season length that's the
sun we spoke about
because the witch queen's out
and jan is it january 22 or about
followed by just 2022 is all we know
it could be january it could be april we
have don't have a firm
anything so even that is a minimum
that's going to
add several weeks to each season that
were due
if we're following the same models last
year which was what four
main like seasonal releases after the
initial and
so time-wise yeah it could be a very
long season it could be potential
four-month seasons on our hands
yeah coming up uh as for story
i i talk about this a lot with my
community when we get
the like i said the tin foil hats on our
spin floyd hats on
and uh it's like there's no cohesive
story right now we've got the whole
crawl
timeline and i think that's developing
really nicely
but everything else is kind of in the
background again like
the like the witch queen they started
touching on that again
last season like the arrival of shiva
raps stuff
and but it's not really it doesn't feel
like it's
starting to converge it feels very open
and if the season is going to go on you
have to
introduce a new like conflict which is
great i mean that's that's how you spend
out these stories but
it leaves other stuff we open questions
and that's
including stuff that's already covered
in the lore um
so i don't know man could could go on
for four or five months
and story-wise no idea i mean we've not
really had a closure for this season yet
the last thing that happened was
against oil alert was the potential
betrayal is of
allah or it looks like the defeat
betrayal
of islands of allah right and it's like
what's going to happen now
um and then obviously the final guardian
game ceremony
is going to be a thing yeah so
or the guy in games as well i've seen i
mean it was like
the witch queen's coming guardian game
yeah look um i don't know i think you
know
it's definitely gonna be longer you know
i'm saying i feel you know definitely
longer season
uh where this is going i think the
problem is we've we've had
such was on such a role narratively
with battlegrounds to get to this very
abrupt stop and then they just gave us
guardian games and
and then you know a whole bunch of iron
banner so
obviously the kyle resolution you know
has to i'm curious how they transition
the end of this season with the uh you
know the kyle stuff
and and crow and all that but with this
next season stuff that you're spoiling
um still don't even know honestly if we
don't know if it's
i don't know splices just sound i don't
know why i'm not excited about that name
i don't know why
but you know it's not you know maybe i
just got to see the trailer i got to see
where it going with it
you know i'm a big fan of siva so i yeah
i would like it back but
it doesn't even have to specifically
receive even if splicers are there
true but i would like stephen okay fair
enough i just want siva back like i just
think it's cool
it's it's it's something sitting in the
vault that they can pull out
you know from uh you know what you call
it what does it play like what they call
it
yeah you know all that stuff then there
was that little
um was it the forge remember the forage
and all that
like i don't know i mean that would be
probably too much of a rip-off of rise
of iron
but um they need they need to do
something i'm just curious to see
cohesively
how the cato thing flows into it because
i don't want it to be a situation where
it's just
a complete cut off from cato we don't
talk about her no more
new thing new new bad new bad you know
you know kind of thing
i i just want some nice you know
cohesion
with this i want to know where the catal
thing goes because clearly she's alive
with us clearly she did not betray us
you know i don't want her to just
disappear
like vintage destiny and then we don't
see her again you know
and yes know what she's actively doing
before we transition into that so yeah
i'm curious
that's probably my main curiosity i'm
always curious narratively when a season
starts
how where they go to it so that's why
man what about what about you
uh yeah i mean if you sit there and you
say
five months you go may june july august
september
and if you do another five months you go
october november december january
february
that at least probably is where i would
picture it to be we've never had a five
month season so then
so the question my main question wonder
is
are they going to try and stick to their
standard cadence we talked about this
last time of
a three-month season normal time frame
for things do their normal stuff
and then do another three month season
with just a big gap or do they stretch
something to five months
so at least whatever narrative they're
trying to connect to which queen
is they'll somewhat closer to that and
again next week is going to tell a lot
somebody's wondering how next week is it
going to go
i would probably put my money on a
teaser on tuesday trailer on wednesday
with the season page and everything on
thursday and the 12
like seems to be what they do yeah
yeah it's going to be trying to be late
well the trailer is going to be lit
awesome music just like total hype
dropping oh yeah
fog oh that you know the trail is going
to be late
of glass turns we get to see what i cora
is up to yeah my car is going to be
voicing it because we've seen the action
wasn't she did she record something
recently
i don't know i thought they saw like for
each um
vanguard i saw like some uh videos well
but actually there was one with nathan
affiliated with cabe i don't know how
old it was but oh that's that's probably
not recent because
yeah yeah but anyway lost our show yeah
like to see
the actress if they if they you know we
haven't heard from my car like what's
going on
the trailer gonna be lit the
excitement's gonna be high the question
is like you said
how long this is gonna this has to be a
long
season i was like that calendar is gonna
tell me exactly
what they're playing i've been waiting
on that one forever because like
what those dates are oh yeah we're
either gonna have
because i mean if it's like this season
front loaded then you get your time to
work on what you want to that's not a
bad thing overall gives you time to play
other stuff there's a lot of other stuff
so i mean it's not like may all of a
sudden got full i was like how did that
happen but it's basically full
um but we'll see how the rest of it goes
and again it's what their comfort is in
letting
basically trials weekends occasional
iron banners and not much other stuff
maintain the game while they work on
like the heavy dev of witch queen
and i'm just kind of curious what they
do like that will be a very very
interesting discussion next week i'm so
curious to see that calendar
oh yeah oh yeah
well as we wrap up and stealing this man
for about two hours
i don't have a whole lot else at this
point um
but the big thing i want to do is thank
this awesome
scotsman from joining us this morning
pigeon
thank you very much for joining us
awesome to have you on
um okay biggest thing right now is
gotta dab um that's my chat stuff to
screw with me
gotta have them uh just like what you
got going on what are you working on
what are you planning for next season
what can they find you what do they see
you doing is there any cool projects
because they haven't i know you work on
some sound stuff too so
floor is yours let everybody who listens
this thing know what is going on in your
world sweet
well thanks for having us first of all
finally good to see you
it's been a long time coming mm-hmm yes
i've been
i said that's a while ago to be honest
but you guys have a solid schedule so
thanks for accommodating me today
and you've been up for breaking early
your way so uh
for those that haven't checked me
already uh i primarily
i'm hanging out on twitch it's twitch.tv
forward slash pidgin
i've actually got announcement coming up
in the next hour
oh you guys might be interested so i'll
follow the twitters or where
where are we looking for that yeah you
can take me on twitter and it's going to
be a
pigeon with an underscore at the end and
other than that we're currently pushing
for partnership on twitch
um other than that i'm i'm pretty much
i've got me shopping listed through in
destiny 2. uh like i said there's
theorycraft and stuff for the the metas
i'm like i've got a few things in mind i
don't want to want to nab so
if i want to come hang out i'll be
chasing that stuff keeping the
conversation going
and yeah
that's all i'm just here to have a chat
to be honest i'm just i love talking
about the game
ouija said this you gotta dave you your
only fans
that's good
i lost it we got a weekly yeah
that's a free one that's three so ouija
are we at someone who
is a's in glasgow sadly it's not out
spoiler it's not good
it's not the only fans but uh it's it's
gonna be a pretty pronouncement for for
everyone
other than that yeah i'll be getting
played for the season i'm already
scheduling time off
to take part in the launch i'm hyped for
potential trailer material next week
i love reacting to those um
that's that's that like vg nothing it
looks like we glee
no i don't know oh i was just a little
far away like the lowercase i so i said
wiggly well now you're weekly
so you can use that pitch you can have
that one
he got me to bust out uh it's you are
now wiggly so
now you're just wiggling wiggly wiggly
wiggly yeah
actually is probably what you say
sounding wiggly
oh man so i think i've been absolute
pleasure and
buzzing to be on and keep doing what
you're doing that's what i'm going to
say
uh all right they told you before we
came on they have been
watching slash listening since pre
forsaken
and like i i see that update episode
updates and spotify try to download
and i didn't swear once by the way
you like you earned you earned a swear
jar like
free buffer when you get back to your
sweet scream stream
let it all out man just get in there and
start the stream with just like a dude
yeah again tremendous to have you on
love what you do in the community love
your energy
hilarious fun you know what i mean shout
out to the i've got your uh
they could talk about your your guitar
skills just the skills
i forgot to shout you out on that you
killed that love what you're doing man
and um yeah we're looking forward to
this announcement
sadly it's not the only fans that the
fans really wanted but yeah i mean
you gotta give it you gotta give the
fans what they want and they want the
only fans
[Laughter]
but we get that but yeah man salute to
you man for sure this was a lot of fun
no doubt uh for me um
yeah seriously man it's like i've
watched you explode and your meteoric
rise has been awesome to watch your
pushing for partner
all i can all i can say is just apply
however many times it takes because you
are damn sure gonna get it
twitch seems to be a pain in the butt
for everybody that i've ever seen
they're like gotta go again gotta go
again
you will definitely get that you 100
deserve it you've been killing it man
that is so awesome
and it's just been pleasant to have you
on this morning had an absolute blast
like cheeks are hurting because we're
having so much fun that's always a good
episode
um yeah so i can't go too wrong with
that one
um but that being said
cog what you got coming up oh what i got
going on oh yeah i know podcast
this sunday get some insider talk he's
been ruffling some feathers so it's
actually a good
time to get this gentleman on it uh is
venture beats own
jeff grubb we'll get all the scoops
we'll talk probably some
eternal you know get what's going on
there and uh also
some latest industry games industry
stuff and sales and
steam and all type of stuff going on so
check us out sunday 1 p.m eastern iron
law podcast
check us out it'll be up there and we'll
have our man jeff grub
also um also some special announcements
be honest uh look out for some special
announcements on that show as well
maybe some giveaways so stay tuned free
stuff
up there free stuff right free stuff
show up man you never free t-shirt
free t-shirt that's all you got to say
free to shoot everybody will be there
everybody read it yeah
so because you'll show that out and then
um yeah man
as far as the website you know i'm
saying lordgaming.net check us out
there we'll have some stuff cooking and
of course
you know the last word is always fun
it's always back my bro
ebatis having fun with the community and
paige man
had a great time brother had a great
time looking forward to see your growth
and
everything you got going on so that's
what i got e what about you
boy eternal what you got oh yeah uh yeah
yeah so i started last night for about
90 minutes i got one run in i'm gonna be
playing as much return i thought it was
gonna have to help a friend's parents
like dig a hole for a pool
so i'm not like i was like i mean not
just me and a shovel there was going to
be more people inside
you yeah i come back on the show and i'm
just like this
like like what'd you do i moved earth i
moved a chunk of
earth so i'm big no um yeah so
it's raining like crazy around here so
we'd just be in a swamp so that's not
gonna happen so
that being said probably a lot of
eternal i am 90 minutes in and a couple
of my friends were literally asking me
this morning is it worth the buy i'm
like i'm 90 minutes in and i want to
just scream from the rafters yes
like i've heard really good things the
reviews are pretty solid but honestly
yeah is just in here yeah he's the one
who needs the flex that man
i have large legs his arms are the size
of my legs
so like i'm usually like of my friends
my legs are like
pretty strong and thick that man beast
mode
doesn't matter he's like oh we have
trucks i just i squat
trucks i see that page oh there we go
yesterday was a pole days no i'm just
kidding uh
he's like oh did somebody you rang
there you go there you go put them away
pidge yeah see too many too many guns on
this podcast we got we gonna get uh
we're gonna get uh out of control in
here but no honestly fraternal so far i
will be streaming
probably all weekend that i can that
because it looks
so far in like the one run i had so cool
so come check that one out i'll be
streaming that one um
but yeah finished ori a lot of cool
stuff and then you know destiny's around
the corner yeah just stay tuned we'll be
breaking down
trailer frame by frame analysis you know
that's gonna come i'm gonna be like
think okay what's in this frame like
we're gonna go through it all so that'll
be next week for me um
but no it's like it's been an absolute
pleasure pidge to have you on
um thank you very much for also your
schedule worked out so we could
occupy even more of your time in our
usual two hour fashions thank you for
staying longer brother
i was like damn i want to talk more
survivor
i loved it well as i said
i got some good news there so um
i was able to stay on pretty much that's
nice that's it i'm
when it could have been cut off time i
was like oh man i'm so glad i can still
stay on yeah so yeah um but
we are gonna go raid silver spear after
this one
she has been killing it on the conqueror
helps right now she has been blown up as
well
part of honestly even a new group as
well so go give some love over to her
she is the one who dragged me to conquer
so her and save the blade he raided us
early at the start of the show
so check out both of those they are
awesome people um so we're gonna go rate
them when we're done
but well let's wrap this episode up it
is april 30th thank you chat you guys
have been
absolutely amazing you guys have been
awesome
just blowing up today pidge brought the
entire coupe in here and you guys have
been cracking me up
uh all the regulars all the new people
thank you follow all of these people
iron lords podcast lord cognito
if you guys are from my world please go
follow pidgeon go you know jump in his
coop and see what's happening in there
because he'll have a good time
and for me and civantas if you find the
cheetah it's me yeah
so for episode number 147 uh
we are not far from 150 we've got an
awesome episode next week we are going
to have ek
the man with the golden vault will be on
talking about all things that is the new
season
so tune in that's gonna be an evening
show next week that'll be 7 p.m eastern
daylight time so
pidge you should be asleep by then but
you'll probably be awake
and other than that uh for this episode
it has been
the last word